and your name is
my name patty patty yeah
Patty oh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up uh and from
Thailand but my hometown Norton isan how
far is that how far eight hour drive
yeah so your family lives there yeah in
Hometown Norton
so you you grew up there
how was your childhood how are you as a
young
boy uh
I think
outside my mom I don't have shirt man I
have everything same lady my family open
heart for Freedom planted I'm lucky
you had a father I have father mother
and my brother
yeah
what age were you when you
when you started realizing you wanted to
be a woman
what age how old were you when you
wanted to realize that you wanted to be
a woman oh I will I I make my booth four
year ago
oh really yes so it's pretty late yes
lit but I take hormone
I think 13 years old I take hormone yes
because I don't uh what looking my body
same man I don't have hair no have
big muscles yeah same man I don't have
yes you always felt like a girl you felt
like a girl yeah
did that cause problems for you in
school
my school
I'm lucky I'm lucky I have red fin for
open heart
no help joking uh M [__] real boy no
yes people didn't make fun of you they
didn't pick on you yeah iFunny in the
friend I Olaf make happy
make friend happy it's great yes
did you have dreams of doing something
some job like you wanted to do something
with your life I have the dreams I think
uh
I've
after my own 30 years old I won't make
new house
uh have one car open little less wrong
in my hometown open a restaurant.com yes
uh no no no my hometown I won't come
back to take care of my family yeah yeah
so you're working at a men's club here
in uh Nana Plaza in Bangkok
yeah yeah
and how long have you worked at the
obsession seven month football for me
first time I go working I'm very excited
because I know half step for talking
and no have experience
for sick with for long
yes
I learning every day I looking
really worked before yes
so the men come by they see you up on
stage they go and I want this one yeah
and they'll go off to a hotel with you
yes you guys have sex and you make some
money yeah Ching I
keep a customer happy customer one I do
I can but sometime and something
customer one I do I cannot do up to my
feeling every day my feeling
sometimes I want new tops sometimes I
want bottom I don't want to control my
feeling I think uh
uh work some job when I happy and I show
my lifestyle I know control something I
happy for work
your work makes you happy
yeah I looking customers my I think I
take care customer really nice you're
like a therapist you make them feel
happy yeah
are there any bad sides to this job
is is it ever a problem for you
emotionally to be doing this kind of
work
um
in the bar
yes and
my language
I think
some customers come inside speak English
accent not same sometimes I don't
understand I can uh until talking slowly
please because I speak English not very
well yes yeah your English is very good
uh I think when I rank
when I run I I can't but when I know
wrong I try a little bit for talking
yeah yes are drugs or alcohol the part
of your life alcohol only alcohol
is it a problem alcohol
just beer
IEC for around
yes
and for I think
customer have said no talking to Martin
just talking a little bit okay
customer life
I serve it
take keep my knee take I go Hotel some
short room no talk too much that's ah
yeah
for sick yes yeah
tell me about your customers are they
from America from Asia from Europe
America my body
I think
uh 90 in America really yeah yes
uh
riosai I I like Asia but I know lucky
because my skin and my toe
my style
look like falang yeah your your Club is
full of beautiful lady boys
really really I mean you're it's pretty
impressive to see the whole group of you
guys together oh thank you so much it's
a
and it's interesting to see the tourists
the men whether they're American Asian
European Australian whatever they yeah
they go in they love that club
I think a lot of men like ladyboys I
think a lot of men like ladyboys some
men I think but no easy for make love
for uh it will be called
my job
I think
that short time for lubli with men I
cannot release
my uh
job cannot release
uh
my life I do before
no easy for
try with men
have you had relationships with with men
before yeah
no lucky
yes I know have experience
I think
uh I just want
to try I opened my heart for lovely yeah
but I I don't want drama because
I start new light now my heart very
strong
I and I think
make happy no help only lovely
girlfriend boyfriend I happy with my
family I'm happy with uh my friend I
happy with I do something I like to do I
love to do
your friends
betraying ahead that's good yes in
Bangkok it's great no easy for help with
fin in my job yeah yeah very competitive
I lucky
yes
so you're sending money to your family
yes some of the money you make you send
back to that I have limit
uh every month eight thousand Baht I
support
yeah 8 000 Baht is roughly about three
hundred dollars uh yes I think a little
bit less than that yes and that's how
much you send every month yes I I uh
every month I make money not not same up
to a customer up to season
yeah
I working I know uh Contour my body too
much because
I just take care of myself yeah yes
mentally you're how are you doing you do
you get depressed sometimes or do you
get angry
uh yes
I think not normally for people
no happy too much no argue too much
but just you know step control your
feeling control your lives because you
think first you are working so with
you don't like you can say in your heart
you smiling you talking real with
consumer for impatient with customer I
think important
yes
right I want money with customer
but
uh no only have sex we need uh [__]
take a shirt go out I won't have a
connection everyone here
yeah you're looking for love like
everyone else yes
does your family know that you do this
kind of work
I think no now
yeah because I Secret
seven months
yes but
no have secret forever
I I think every day Someday my family
know
my family don't ask me food
uh what I do
but I know may compound with my family I
know may compare with my life
every job have good and not good
right yeah just you open heart you
lovely for your job you uh lovely for
your life for you want to do
I think yes
do you have dreams like what would you
like to be doing in five or ten years
would you like to get married would you
like to adopt kids
now I forgot for make money go to get go
to my dreams
yes restaurant yes but what about what
about love what about marriage for uh
for
culture
not sure
yes are ladyboys allowed to get married
in in Thailand
uh
I don't know many
uh [__] thing not same
yeah I just I think I planning for my
life
I think uh many people were lucky in the
light
yeah but you cannot forget and
uh have a dream too much for Mary for
Rocky
but not sure in the light someday yes
you happy someday you hurt
that's you when you have mini pom-pam in
your life you can make power for go
together
you are lying yourself your body go
is your life fairly
Problem free or do you have a lot of
drama in your life a lot of problems
have I have many drama but
I
uh learning in drama I learning in the
problem
yes I learn infinite I released because
have many
drama when you have like
yeah it's part of life yes
but some people attract chaos into their
lives
I I like learning how old are you
uh my own 27 you're 27 yeah you're still
young thank you you're learning
you have good memories as a child
have every memory a good and not good
yes
what were the bad memories
um
I don't know
every I think I wake up I have the rice
good
for me
yes
I I don't know what
I think
I do good my life good
yeah in general your life is good yes
seems like being transgender is very
accepted here in Bangkok
uh easy
I think yes but have only one no open
100 for transgender for the job some job
no open for transgender yes
do you feel like regular jobs are not
available to you because you're
transgender
uh yeah sometimes I can do some job
cannot
but up to uh your light record many
transgender thing not same but for me
I don't like a working sit in table I
want learning I want new experience
every day
you're so convincing as a female yeah
you're very feminine
I know yeah you seem to
have the ability to if you got a job at
a at an office and they might not want
to hire a transgender they would hire
you you're a woman
same woman
not saying 100 percent
for transgender real woman real woman
have Charming not same you think people
know the difference
different yes that you looking your
lifestyle and you can choose your
Charming in your light
show with many people
yes do you feel like being a transgender
woman is not the same as being a woman
um
not not same 100 percent
yes
but you're not looking to remove some of
your male parts me yeah
uh again you're not looking to remove
some of your male parts me yeah
I uh
don't want operation
because I think Charming for transgender
and miracle for transgender
uh my personality same lady but when
opened have wow you have same man
I think and you're cool with that and
you're fine with that yes just as you
are
live with me 7 27 years over stay my
sister
yeah yeah so
editing
a little bit woman a little bit man is
is a good thing
yes sometimes
and what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
lifetime what would you say is the most
life
most important lesson you've learned
um
for me I just I just think
myself I can
I can make happy I can make hurt
many people
know used my life same the toy My Life
in Belize
I think
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story okay thank you